chris hemsworth was initially turned  down for the role of thor when he first  auditioned i think my audition sucked  chris's younger brother liam then  auditioned and got very close to landing  the role but was turned down for being  too young chris was then brought back  into audition and this time he nailed it  i just had a different attitude maybe i  had a little a little more sort of  motivation that my little brother had  got to look in and i hadn't chris cited  the movies he worked on between  auditions as the extra experience he  needed to give him a confidence boost so  i had a bit more experience and  confidence in what i was gonna do